[Music]
welcome back President Trump has a
message for Democrats support Nancy
Pelosi yeah the president tweeting this
Democrats please do not distance
yourself from Nancy Pelosi she is a
wonderful person whose ideas and
policies may be bad but who should
definitely be given a fourth chance she
is trying very hard and has every right
to take down the Democratic Party if she
has feared too far left
someone was good enough tries hard
enough and - gone and he's a great guy
great lad felt here to weigh in co-host
of the five author of the brand new book
the gutfeld monologues classic rants
from the five how did you come up with
the title it was hard I spent months I
did some market research and I realized
my name is great and I write monologues
so I put them together it was originally
called the gutfeld hoax and then liars
losers and leakers but then I thought
you know what I'm gonna do this Greg
maybe you could run for House Speaker I
I would love to I think it'd be pretty
good yeah but they'd have to change the
podium because I can't see over it yeah
what do you make though with the fact
that you do have a number of folks
within Nancy Pelosi zone party fresh
faces that are coming you've got
candidates but also people that are
already on the job saying we want out
yeah I don't know it that could change
once everything because she's pretty
powerful you know it's like you can
complain to your parents all the time
but when they yell dinner you come to
the table the tweet though is fantastic
that's great a trolling it's like a an
insult
wrapped in a dif compliment disguises
the defense it's kind of like saying oh
isn't it great that you have ed Henry on
Fox & Friends you know he's trying so
hard and it keeps him busy out of
trouble you know
Edie that's it's a very unique we have a
very unique leader whether you love him
or hate him
our president goes on Twitter in trolls
people and it's and it's good humoured I
think that's a good-humoured tweet I
mean let's face it he does get along
with Pelosi he's daring Democrats to
promote her yeah right before the
midterm exam you should exactly fourth
times a charm but you added yet her to
the socialist from the Bronx I mean
these are good he's pointing out the
obvious that yeah longer we talk about
them the better it is for Republic yeah
it is except
I do think though the more you talk
about okay CEO Cortez I think the better
she's gonna get because she's gonna
react to the criticism so and that's why
I think she's she well maybe I'm wrong
though I haven't seen the improvement
yet but I have a feeling I always
believe that criticism helps you that's
why I'm not constantly writing you those
emails I know late at night the
criticism also is fair that so the grunt
the gutfeld monologue right so people
are wondering what that is and if you're
watching you know what it is because
watch Greg here's just a little snippet
crushes you could see the jokes limping
toward you
the dinners now just old news good job
Santa Barbara like the straws you try to
ban you suck but I like the straws not
in a good way the world's getting hotter
and it's not global warming it's
political tension driven by emotion who
knew De Niro's lasting role would be
irrelevant gasbag pleasing irrelevant
peers monologues are classic people wait
for them they want them they usually
start with scribble on a paper
yes exact exactly where do you get the
inspiration every day I wake up every
morning strong cup of coffee I look at
what's on TV and I go what's not been
said that's step one and I try to figure
out what the topic what is the angle
that they haven't heard and then I try
to make that angle such that it's when
you hear you go that's exactly what I
was thinking so the viewers when they're
listening to me they go he's saying
exactly what I'm thinking but I haven't
articulated it like that so it's a
two-step process what's not been said
and what matches the is the unspeakable
truth that lives inside your heads
how much do you mention robots and
unicorns in the book I think about 40
percent of the book is robots thirty
percent is unicorn oh yeah and then the
rest let's to be real so your mind works
on another plane of analogies and
comparisons where do you come up with
some of this the the comparison do you
use to make things relevant well I come
up with them when III pretend that I use
this tip and I mentioned the book I
pretend that I'm drunk because you know
that you always have an opinion or a
comparison when you're slightly tipsy so
I just sit there and I go okay you know
you know the the Democratic agenda is
as thin as brian Stelter z' hair you
know something that alignment I've often
you sorry Brian but you get we get along
but anyway that's what happened so you
just keep and also I'll step into the
into the hallway of our pod and if I
can't think of something so I'll start
the sentence you know and I'll say like
you know I don't know the Democratic
agenda is as bloated as and then someone
will say Michael Moore after three
pizzas and I go yeah that's too obvious
besides they use that yesterday but
that's how you do it you play ping pong
with your coworkers it's very good it's
helped with people I won't be making
jokes about the view anymore though a B
as long as you're on it how am I gonna
do that you've ruined the view for me
now you're gonna make it well I like
Megan to but guys thanks for getting up
early for us my pleasure
all this kind of sad Trump monologues
check it out alright meanwhile I'm just
kidding you gotta come on